madame la Première ministre la France
libératrice du Mali est chassé d'Afrique
quasiment sans préavis
Centrafrique Burkina Faso etc
la France est grande puissance
diplomatique qui a normalement
langage
universel qui doit parler à tout le
monde cette France se fâche avec ses
partenaires la même réussie à se fâcher
en même temps il faut le faire avec le
Maroc et l'Algérie
on est donc face à un échec diplomatique
cuisant dramatique pour l'avenir
j'allais vous demander quel est votre
politique pour l'Afrique mais le
président de la République a déclaré le
27 février qui avait plus de politique
française en Afrique alors est-ce vrai